[Music]
well welcome to another episode of the
addie hour
i did want to start off today just
acknowledging all of our listeners all
of you who've been listening over these
last few weeks definitely appreciate the
notes that people have sent it's been
really encouraging to hear
how encouraging these conversations have
been for you how things have resonated
with you
what you've learned from them for the
inspiration as well and so just want to
acknowledge
acknowledge that and thank you for all
of your support in these conversations
so far
today i'm really excited we're going to
be jumping deep into this conversation
at the intersection of mental health and
faith
and today it's one of those where we
have four unique individuals in the room
so i'm a little bit curious to see
what's going to happen when we have a
pastor
a psychiatrist and a theologian a social
worker and a neuroscientist all together
in the same space
i think that's a conversation that could
go a lot of different directions but i
think it's going to be really
really fun and informative for us is
really dig into these these
topics and conversations today so with
that i'd like to go ahead and welcome
our three guests
the first is michael walron jr also
known as pastor mike
pastor mike is the senior pastor of the
first corinthian baptist church in
harlem he's a prolific and sought-after
teacher and preacher
a visionary a cultural architect and a
game changer
pastor mike has lots of accolades that
he's accumulated over the years too
numerous to list here
but i did want to mention that in 2015
mayor de blasio did name pastor mike as
the first
chair of the new york city clergy
advisory council
and pastor mike has also been involved
in a lot of different initiatives in the
community two that i just want to
highlight in 2012
his church launched the dream center
which provides over 25 completely free
programs to the harlem community
to its members all of all ages races and
backgrounds
in 2016 he also opens the hope center
the healing on purpose and evolut
evolving center which is the first
faith-based mental health facility in
harlem
so we're deeply just honored and
thankful for the work that he's been
doing in the community over the years
and grateful that he's here to join the
podcast today thanks so much for being
here pastor mike thank you for having me
of course our second guest is dr green
dr lena green is a clinical social
worker
a psychotherapist and a fatherhood
practitioner who currently serves as the
executive director of the hope center
dr green has also earned lots of
different accolades over the years
did want to mention one in particular in
2019
dr green received the national
association of social workers
new york city's chapter social work
impact award
and this award is presented to a social
worker who exemplifies
a commitment to social justice equity
empowerment
and civil rights through their work
research advocacy
practice embodiment of the social work
profession and also their dedication to
communities and individuals they serve
so again someone who's been deeply
invested in this work over the
years and we're grateful to be able to
have dr green join us on the broadcast
today
thanks for being here thanks for having
me
and our third guest is dr warren
kinghorn
dr king horn is a psychiatrist who
teaches at the duke university
medical school he also is a co-director
of the theology
medicine and cultural initiative at duke
divinity school
which offers opportunities to students
in health professions and depressing
clinicians
who are studying for seminary as well so
he's written a lot of different topics
over the years
including the philosophy of psychiatric
diagnoses the moral dimensions of combat
trauma
and the role of clinician patient
relationships specifically as that
relates to medicine
medication prescribing he's also written
about the way that christian communities
understand mental health and mental
illness
so a lot of work that's relevant to this
conversation today and grateful to have
dr king horn here with us
welcome thank you really pleased to be
here
well again i think it's going to be a
great conversation we have all these
different perspectives that we bring to
the table
but as i often do on these podcasts just
want to start out just checking in with
everybody and seeing how you're doing in
the midst of everything that's happened
the last few weeks over the last year
and a half and even beyond that
so pastor mike if we could go ahead and
start with you
yeah no i i am well i mean
the past 18 months i think for all of us
has been challenging in different ways
um
for those of us who are in the church
you know many have had to reimagine how
we do church
you know and how we serve the needs of
the community and the people who are
part of the congregation
and i've been blessed um because we had
a place where
i feel like we were already a little
ahead
of the game already so much what we did
was digital that
our virtual uh ministry and programming
was already up we just had to increase
content
so i'm grateful for the amazing team and
staff we have at fcbc on a personal
level i mean
my wife and i are both vaccinated fully
vaccinated and
we also both had uh a covet
and we did not have easy bouts with it
either
it was extremely challenging um and i i
was i was one of the early
we were the early some of the early
people who had it when people didn't
know what it was
um in january we were just extremely
sick and
she couldn't breathe and i had to call i
had pneumonia in both lungs
and it was after everything kind of got
chaotic in new york city
and we went back and got an antibody
test and found that we had we were
positive for the antibodies so we knew
that when we were sick that's what it
was because it was it was
it was worse it started out feeling like
a flu but it was ten times worse
and uh it was horrific but i'm grateful
uh we had it my son had it who lives up
here as well
um and um but we we we came through it
and as a congregation we're doing well
and personally we're doing well so i'm
grateful
grateful well i'm glad to hear and i
appreciate you sharing you know so
honestly about that path i mean
i missed the challenges and even going
through kobe and not knowing that that's
what it was i can only imagine
yeah all that all that came with that
thank you thanks so much for for sharing
so apparently i imagine that's also
a source of strength to have that
testimony about what you've gone through
as well at the same time absolutely
absolutely
and and especially those like you said
those who've gone through it
and also those who are still fearful you
know that's why we really push
vaccination we wear a vaccination site
and we'll be again in the fall
but it's important not community so yeah
that's so so important so well said
what about you dr green how is this last
year and a half and even these last few
weeks been for you
oh well it's been it's been a bit of a
mixed bag and grateful to be on the
other side of it
um so with regard to work just
super excited about the opportunity that
i have to work at the hope center i
actually started here
during the pandemic so i started in
september
2020 um when i received the invitation
for my pastor to
take on this new role and excitedly did
so
um and grateful that it's thriving we're
pretty much offering which i know we'll
have a chance to talk about later but
offering
an array of programs to the community so
i'm grateful for that
on a personal note i've definitely had
some personal challenges during the
pandemic i too have lost
two family members to covid
unfortunately
and then had some other medical issues
um that i
you know had to face during covit so you
know
went in for a surgery um and found out
that i was allergic to anesthesia
and ended up in the icu um and since
then i've actually
been seeing an herbalist um who has
really helped me to sort of you know
stay healthy um in addition to just you
know exercising and doing the best
around my mental health but
making sure that i'm fueling my body
with good stuff and just
looking at my health from a holistic
standpoint so i'm grateful
for where i am right now well well
thanks for sharing sharing so honestly
as well and i think
it's great i mean you're in a way living
by example
and talking about really taking that
holistic approach and making sure that
your
your health is good all the way around
even despite those challenges
so it seems in some ways here again also
on the other side
just going through yeah and i tell
everybody who
excellent dr king horn what about you
yeah i am doing okay i i've been
fortunate to have a
job this whole time and patients to see
and students to teach and
and uh reasonably good health and my
family's
done okay but i have to say i'm just
tired right now it both at the end of a
semester but also in the midst of just
everything that
has been going on and i i've just been
um
increasingly aware in the last year
really how
not just heavy everything around this is
whether it's a
patient of mine who like the green has
lost two immediate family members to
covet
to veterans that i care for at the va
hospital here in durham who are really
upset at what happened on january the
6th and like really kind of had the
world rocked and
seeing that to i taught a class on
theology and trauma here at duke this
spring and we tried to continue just to
be aware of what was happening in our
world and have even this spring
you know the shootings in atlanta and
the
repeated ongoing killings of people of
color
whether it's dante wright and more
recently andrew brown here in north
carolina
and seeing the way that my students are
bearing the weight of that and feeling
that and
and on top of having an ongoing pandemic
it just feels like a really
challenging season so i'm both grateful
and also
um just aware of how much is going on
all around us
yeah that makes a lot of sense a lot of
ways and definitely appreciate
your awareness of that as well i mean
you're leaning off talking about
i imagine you do this with your students
as well but your own tiredness so not to
ignore that but to acknowledge and i
think all of us have
done that and acknowledged i mean
clearly if you know some having gone
through covert as pastor mike mentioned
and
you know dr green also mentioned some of
the health challenges just just the
reality of what we're all dealing with i
think that goes a long way
um i imagine that will come from the
conversation as well but i feel like
that's often a starting point just
acknowledging
the challenges and then you know dr king
orange you mentioned
also acknowledging the challenges your
students are going through and
empathizing even if you
can't relate to every single component
of it but just being there is that voice
and that that empathetic uh support to
really say okay these are challenging
times and it's not something that we can
just
ignore and plow through and i think a
lot of ways that
ties into this conversation the
intersection of mental health and faith
i'm going to pass it on to pastor mike
and dr green to elaborate on but i would
say even in my own experiences
in academic settings in the community
oftentimes
there isn't that acknowledgement at the
first pass so you know i've talked to
students who said oh my aunt is
struggling with depression she's being
told the only reason she's not getting
better
is because she isn't praying hard enough
so yes acknowledging the power of god
but not acknowledging all the tools we
have at our disposal to address those
things
but at the same time i'll be teaching
students who will get very excited about
the biology of the brain and how that
impacts mental health but say things
like what are we supposed to do with
those people that think
a higher power can help them with their
mental health challenges or being
a part of a faith community so again now
being totally dismissive
about the other side of things i mean i
think oftentimes
there's not enough conversation about
how we need to look at those things
holistically
and so that's one of the reasons i'm so
excited about this conversation and the
work that you
all have been involved in either on the
ground or
as admirers and advocates of the work
and so you know pastor mike and dr grant
i just wanted to hear a little bit about
the journey into that space of even
creating
that hope center i mean this is the
first faith-based mental health
center in harlem it's unique in a lot of
ways and i'm curious how all that came
about in the first place
well i i'll talk about that piece and
when we get to the exciting work
of the hope center i'll let dr green
jump on it
um the journey really started
towards the hope center as personal um
i suffer with a rare disease
it's called cvid common variable
immunodeficiency
and basically i i was born with no
antibodies
um with with a very low life expectancy
and but what it has meant over the years
there's numerous infections
numerous hospitalizations surgeries
you you name it near-death experiences
sepsis i've survived sepsis three times
um two of the three times i mean you
know science was mrsa which is the worst
bacteria to get
i mean so over the years though what it
caused
is is a lot of depression you know when
you're battling with chronic illness
chronic sickness chronic pain um it has
an impact and i was doing
dealing with all this wild pasturing in
many ways and it got to be a lot and i
found myself
in and out of depressive moments
and i never at that time going back into
the early 2000s and beyond
never sought out a therapist i think not
that i was against therapy i just never
thought to look for a therapist i
figured you know i can handle it i'm a
pastor i
i preach every week i teach i lead
people through these moments i can come
out of it
and then in 2010
or seven rather i was on a trip in
to seattle washington and i was staying
at a hotel on the 22nd floor of the
hotel
and nothing there was nothing going on
that day that seemed strange or
different
um and i remember going out on the
balcony
and i literally heard a voice tell me
say to me
you know if you jump you can survive
that's what i heard it was the first
time i heard anything close to suicidal
ideation
ever voices said if you jump you can
survive and i remember
you know kind of feeling another
presence kind of pulled me back into
this room off the balcony and i remember
laying in his bed almost in fetal
position just crying i didn't know what
just happened
but it was very overwhelming because in
my entire life i never thought of the
idea never conceived of it never entered
my mind about
the notion of taking my own life and i
was able to understand that's what was
just happening
and it was literally a voice as clear as
you and i are talking now dr knee i
heard say that if you jump you can
survive
and so that was kind of the first alarm
that something is is
is not not well and again
still pushing through it still fighting
through it still not
seeing a therapist while at the same
time people are coming to me for
pastoral care
and counseling while at the same time in
2012
uh dr kinghorn i was in i was in durham
to preach and got sick on a wednesday
at duke medical center by friday and
spent 14 days at duke medical center
with sepsis and i had mrsa and they had
no idea what i survived
and um when i came out of that in 2012
i remember when i got better someone
wanted to see me about some issues they
were dealing with personally
and over the years we had the pastors
have always gotten
had sessions with people whose issues
were beyond our ability to handle we
found ourselves always referring
to spaces where they can get mental
health care
and i said to myself one i need to
find a therapist and then i said
you know there are people who are coming
to the church who who are in need of
care beyond what we're capable of giving
so when i started my journey
in therapy is when we look to hire
a part-time therapist on staff um
to deal with some of the issues that
will be on our scope as pastors
all of the training all of us had you
know pastoral care and counseling
clinical pastoral education but there
were still things we just could not deal
with
so we hired her name was at the time
joyce johnson
and it was pretty soon she got swamped
right she she was
there and she got overloaded with things
but one day when i was at the church in
the lobby because when you come to the
information desk
if in the entrance you know the
reception's like who are you here to see
joyce had an office upstairs in the
church
and i'm sitting in the lobby the person
didn't know who i was at they were not
a member of the church and but they came
in
and when the receptionist asked the
person who would they come and see
they they whispered joyce's name
i perceived in that moment there was
still some shame like i'm coming here to
see someone
you know about some some issues and you
know the stigma you know
i'm not crazy or nothing's wrong but i
noticed them whispering and i realized
at that moment
and this was in 2000 towards the maybe
the beginning 2013
i said having this space is not enough
i want to have a freestanding space so
people feel comfortable going in because
if you come to church and you go to see
joyce people think you're crazy that's
what people that's what i was feeling
you know and so i had been looking
so we have the dream center that you
talked about which is really cutting
edge you do a lot of programming
but we got the space because of a
relationship with one of our trustees
who was also developer
and when he asked about getting some
community support for this project he
had
yeah i said well look we're going to
give you support but i got an idea that
first floor
of your building let us get that
building we'll pay rent and we use it
for the dream center well
in 2014 he needed support for another
space around the corner from the church
i said listen let's do the same thing
let's get this space in that moment it
was like instant
let's use this space for a mental health
facility
and that's where it started um and for
about a year and a half they worked on
the space we were able to build it out
and then we had the ribbon cutting in
december of 2014
um a 16 rather for the
um for the hope center and we named it
hope
we had dream and now we had hope um
healing on purpose and evolving when we
offer it initially we've changed it but
initially
people who who came into the hope center
and went through the process we didn't
call them clients
we call them hope innovators you want to
change the language
um persons who are creatively
finding paths towards healing and
wholeness
just changing language changing the
culture changing the dynamic
but initially when you came and you went
through the program of the application
you got
12 free therapeutic sessions plus
follow-up plus potentially
involved in group sessions as well so
with something that had never been
i mean you think about the cost of 12
sessions of therapy and we were offering
this for free
initially we had some people who volunt
we had
a staff but then we had two volunteers
two women who
who um it was amazing they had visited
the church
and they weren't they were actually
jewish but they had been visiting the
church of
quite a bit they really liked the church
and they were psychiatrists
and so they offered their services wow
like that first
year or so year to one got ill with
cancer but they were offering their
services free and because of their
presence
they were offered to prescribe
medication if necessary so we had our
staff
of clinicians plus we had these two
psychiatrists volunteering their
services every weekend
so it was amazing how things just
unfolded and persons started making
donations
and we were i mean it was just great um
and because i was able to believe we
build this space people will come
and it was to meet a particular need
because you know the stigma
in the black community that exists
around mental health and
um mental health issues and so we wanted
to engage in de-stigmatizing that
and then i from the pulpit began
preaching
about my personal battles with
depression
and anxiety and that opened up what i
thought if if the pastor can be
transparent
if i can talk about it it'll free other
people up to feel hey it's okay to talk
about it
and it's okay to acknowledge it and by
the way then we have a space
that can help you navigate this so yeah
i'll stop there now
wow that's so powerful that's amazing to
hear to hear that story you know just
from your personal journey and
everything that came out in the
community as well
i think that's so it's so important that
you are you are acknowledging that
from the pulpit as well because i think
that helps people in those moments to
know it's not a quick fix
so i'm sure that's some of what comes in
to it as well i mean when i started
about that student
basically it's the the mindset that
it hasn't been fixed yet because you're
not putting enough effort in your
prayers
yeah for god to address that but you
mentioned that from the pulpit and so
people know
the journey i think that's so so
important yeah and i had those same
comments before this
and you know i had a woman say to me
one time a a member of the church she
said well pastor you know i
i understand what you're doing but you
know i i gotta trust god and i believe
you know demons and she went through
this whole thing
and i i asked i said you have any um
physical ailments and she told me yes
she said i have
have diabetes i said
so is god dealing with that or you got
medication
yeah and she said well i i take insulin
shot i said oh i said okay so you trust
the doctors
with the diabetes but you don't trust
practitioners with mental health issues
and she just paused
and she just paused and and that was a
reality huh yeah you know
there's no stigma around going to the
hospital when you're sick
right we often talk about that you break
your arm nobody's saying oh my god
you're gonna go to the hospital to get
that fixed
no but there's a stigma around issues
around the spirit around the mind around
the soul
and and we have to do that work of
really like i said
demythologizing and destigmatizing yeah
uh those issues and i think the more we
do it
and the more we've been talking about it
we've seen a change in the language of
people
in the community and also having a space
it's one thing to talk about it from the
pulpit
and to make it a priority church it's
another thing to have a space
that you can say by the way here's the
therefore
yeah here's the therefore therefore
there is this space so
yeah that's so important so important
i'm so so uh
honored to be you know just hearing
about the work that you've been doing on
the ground a sense to really set this up
i was going to pivot to dr green and
hear a little bit about some of that as
well and even just you know one of the
points that pastor mike that you brought
up
as i was listening to it seemed like
that tension was ongoing you talked
about the first person who came in who
was volunteering who was overwhelmed
so obviously there's a need when she was
in volunteering you know she
was getting paid she was going okay okay
she was part-time she yeah
we wanted to make sure we got good stuff
that's good yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah so even and even as she's doing
that being overwhelmed but then people
are still whispering
about going this year so it seems like
both of those were kind of happening at
the same time
so you know dr graham here like how has
that
moved forward on the ground level as a
director how do you see that play out do
you feel like you're
dealing with both simultaneously are
people getting better at acknowledging
the need are you still trying to
break through this stigma what's that
whole process like at this point
yes i would say it's a little bit of
both right um and so
for me um you know my mantra has always
been
you can pray and go to therapy right um
so i'm also very active in the community
and always have been right and so
people have always known that i'm a
mental health permission therapist
um and so having those conversations
with people has always been something
that's been super easy for me right
um and so pastor brought up the brought
up the example of talking to the woman
about her medical
condition and would she go to the
hospital to seek treatment for that
right and that's a great place to start
because i think it's helping people to
unpack
you know their thought process around
mental health treatment right and there
are all these things that sort of go in
there
um but part of it also too is this i
think this conspiracy of silence around
you know these mental health challenges
that people have experienced
for many many years um and haven't
really had an opportunity to talk about
it
um we can talk about the issues around
discrimination and racism that have also
plagued the mental health system that
has
impacted people's ability to trust
the systems of care that are in place um
feeling like they can also
seek treatment and places and with
people who also look like them right
um so all those things sort of go into
that and so i think we do a good job at
keeping the conversation open and
transparent and clear and also not
taking ourselves too seriously right
like
just saying hey we have this thing here
um it's free and it's available
and you know i'll say things to folks
like where can you go and get something
for free
right how often can you go and do that
and they're like well you know what
and then you know i may i may say to
them you know what are some of the
things that are important
you know what i'm talking to some of the
millennials who want to have a
conversation around you know the cost of
mental health and i say well
you know how often do you shop right um
how much did you pay for for the last
pair of shoes right
um and the same ways in which you go for
brunch or you go shopping right it's
building
um space into your life and making
spaces you like things that are
important to you and so how do you
prioritize that and then if your
mental health is not a priority well
then let's talk about that too right so
there are always these ongoing
conversations around how to open up
um the door just to have the
conversation and to make it welcoming
um and so we've done our best to do that
here so
you know we offer the sessions uh but
one of the things that has been
important to me um is making sure that
we have
a ton of public racing programs as well
and so we have right now implemented
what we call our healing conversations
on a monthly basis
and we tackle really tough issues
at least once a month um and so we've
tackled
suicide we've tackled domestic violence
we've tackled grief and loss actually
last month
this month we're going to be talking
about anxiety and then in june
which will be our last healing
conversation we're going to be talking
about the importance of sleep
and rest um and what does that mean in
our daily lives
um you know i've also been able to
develop some fantastic partnerships with
a bunch of organizations in the
community
um we don't see children here our folks
that the folks that we see here are 18
and over
so it's been important for us to
cultivate relationships with
places that provide services to
adolescents and children and so we've
been in the process of trying to develop
that as well
um but one point um with regard to the
need
is that when i came here to the hope
center we had a waiting list of 76
people
wow and some of those folks had been on
the waiting list for over a year
and so one of my first priorities was to
sort of look at that list
um go back to those folks and prioritize
like who was sort of in high need of
care
services who was in crisis um and then
we were also still in the middle of
copenhagen so how could we then provide
programming that serves people who were
also suffering from loss and so we've
been in the process of doing that
um so two relationships that we've um
built that i've been so proud to
participate in is um our
partnership with columbia university
center for complicated grief
so all of my staff here including the
interns have been trained in complicated
grief services
um they also get you know rigorous
suicide training and mental health
counseling training of course um i'm a
field instructor as well
as well as a professor at nyu and i'm an
adjunct faculty there so
um i get to you know make sure that i'm
being consistent with the
kinds of um training and teaching that
students need here
to be successful clinicians out in the
community we also make sure that we pay
attention to
um you know issues of race issues of
power and privilege
all of those things right and making
sure that the staff here is also quite
diverse
um and so you know we do all of that we
make sure
that um we are paying attention to our
own mental health needs
um so when pastor mike was talking you
know one of the things that
has always been taught to me by my own
mentors um
is that you know the healers need
healing and the healers need spaces to
go
as well and so making supervision um
part of and therapy you know a
consistent part of your life
and so that's why this year um you know
we came up with
our our tagline um for our theme this
year which is healing is a lifestyle
to really cultivate and encourage folks
to continue on that path the whole
and and and that journey to wellness
that's so great i mean that's such a
holistic approach too and you're
tackling so many things
at once which are so critical i mean
even you know dealing with the stigma on
the front end
making sure that you're covering all the
different topics that influence mental
health including sleep
uh making sure that you're you know
talking about the impact of
the racial injustices and racism and and
then partnering with those
outside so i think in so many ways this
this model that you all have developed
is
so important and so effective um and so
dr kinghorn i'm actually curious you
know as someone who's been
an admirer and advocate of this work
what what are some of the things that
have stood out to you about
just the importance of the work that
they're doing um in harlem and what has
caught you
your eye as someone who has you know
your your foot in both worlds both in
a faith community and as a psychiatrist
yeah thank you yeah i've been a distant
admirer of the hope center for
quite a while i first learned about hope
center through the work of my colleague
in psychiatry sydney hinkerson at
columbia university
who is doing really unique research
federally funded research
on the role of faith communities and
especially of churches and depression
intervention
and i've learned a lot from dr
hankerson's work one of his
early uh published papers which he
published in a in the journal of urban
health
was an uh focus group study with pastors
at a
a church in new york in queens so it
wasn't first corinthian baptist but he
i interviewed a lot of of uh pastors
around their experience in a
predominantly african-american
large church in new york city around how
they encountered depression
and these pastors recognized that
depression was present in their
community they wanted the church to be a
site of support and they also really
helpfully though said
uh we have to think about depression not
just as like an individual medical
problem that needs treatment but we need
to also
situate it in the context of the lived
realities of people's lives
of job stress financial stress of racism
of problems with education and
accessing medical care and and it
pointed to
the way in which churches can actually
be sites
of outreach and support and connection
even more but partnering with medical
systems but how can churches be
do that kind of connecting work and
especially not just recognizing
the way in which mental health problems
don't exist in a vacuum they
they take place in a kind of community
and culture and sets of relationships
and
and so when i hear about the hope center
being situated within a church made
possible by a church
providing pathways to high quality
mental health care and
also though responding to the needs of
the local community which in some ways
is the needs of our entire country i'm
just really excited about it and just
um just really have been so excited to
see it grow over the years and
to hear about its work and uh to hear
more about it through my
uh connections at dick divinity school
with pastor mike
yeah that's so well said it's so
encouraging to hear about the work
that's being done on multiple fronts
and some of these connections as well i
know dr hankson has been very well
uh connected to this initiative and i
think you know so much that
others can learn as well and so i'm
actually curious you know as you all
have been moving through this and
kind of breaking down some of these
barriers and empowering people are there
other aspects that you think can be
expanded and used and applied in other
places as well is it something that's
unique to the environment that you have
and harlem the relationships there or
are the principles that you that you see
that could actually be replicated by
others in other parts of the country
well you know a few things one
um well two things actually one
i've had conversations with other
colleagues in ministry
about the hope center you know and
wanting to do this
um wanting to try to replicate it in
some way shape or form
and the conversation at some point
turns into a conversation about church
budgets
right i'll tell you why because the
first question is resources
you know we used to be told you know
budgets are moral documents
right and i would say no budget
budgets are vision documents to me you
know
where do you see yourself where do you
want to go as a church
and the reason why i brought this up is
because when we opened the hope
center for the first few years there was
no public money it was
all church donations that funded it it
staffed it that kept it going
and what we made a priority for the
church initially
is that this was important this was
meeting and needing the community
and we we put our resources where the
need is
and this was a great need and uh
and so the people believed in it the
church believed in it the leadership
believed in it
and were able to give to it to make sure
that it was able to function and sustain
itself
that's the first thing i think a lot of
times in ministry
we do ministry based on ideas not always
need
and so i had to tell a lot of my
colleagues that um
and and it became important secondly you
know
myself and dr hankerson and others have
talked about you know
using the hope centers like this kind of
spoken wheel model it can be replicated
i think if more faith-based institutions
had this kind of of presence in the
community
it could go a long way again in in
in destigmatizing um the narrative
and and what you find is that many
faith-based institutions want to do it
but they begin
talking about resources so you know
i think there are institutions that have
the capacity to do it
but i think there are tons of resources
out
there for people to begin these
initiatives but i do think there's a
willingness
by many clergy so that's one of my
dreams to see
hope centers and other places i've
talked with dr green about this
that you know how do we how do we make
this happen
in in other parts of the city for now
and then make it something that
transcends the city
right because it it serves a great need
listen it is a reality
we're doing a great work dr green and
our team are doing a great work
but we we're still in some ways
overwhelmed and
we run out of space right so it was like
when we opened it from within
i would say within the first nine months
we realized we were already tapped off
of spades
right so it it so we
dr green has talked to me about that
about needing a bigger space which is a
good thing
right so that we can offer more services
and have a more adequate space conducive
for the kind of clinical work that's
being done
so i i'm just you know i'm i'm i'm
grateful for these challenge the
challenges we have
but i'm also grateful for the
possibilities
and um i'm grateful for dr green
because i think she not only has the
ability but the vision
to make the larger vision come to pass
for the hope
center so
i just want to add two about with regard
to um you know resources
and i you know i wasn't there in the
beginning i've been connected to the
first time the baptist church since 2006
right in working in ministry
um under pastor mike for quite a while
before i came to the host center
but one of the things that i will say is
that you know just beginning the
conversations around mental health
and seeing what resources are within you
know your own congregation
right because i think you would be
surprised about um
what may come you know what may come up
um you know
uh pastor mike talked about these two
psychiatrists who decided that they
wanted to donate their time
right so i think just beginning there
and having the conversation and being
open about the kinds of things that you
need
and the kinds of things that you'd like
to see um i wanted to mention also too
that
with dr henkerson one of the things that
we did at fcbc was
um do this mental health first aid
training
and that started with um dr hankerson
training
our pastors and our deacons initially
um and then opening that up to other
volunteers who were interested in just
having a basic understanding of a
one-on-one
on mental health first aid and sort of
how to intervene in a crisis right
and so you don't necessarily always have
to have experts on hand
that's a great place for you to you know
for you to start right and then that
sort of develops into other things and
so
you know one of the things that we're
doing now um in partnership with dr
hankerson
um is in june we're going to be
embarking on a study
that focuses on understanding the
experiences of depression and black men
and so we're really looking forward to
that because we know that some
additional really good information about
how to provide
uh resources and services and engage um
men overall so you know i think just
again starting the conversation seeing
what resources you have with it and just
starting you know
making the commitment to start somewhere
yeah i think it's so great that you both
you know really pulled that out
and i want to add to that if you think
about i remember when this was before
the hope center was really an idea we
had uh joyce johnson
miss johnson and dr hanks and i were
having numerous conversations so when we
did the mental health first
uh responders kind of training we had
almost 300 people that ended up being
trained wow
right and and it was amazing because
they realized not only
was they need but it was an interest
from the community to help
and to be a part of this and it was
amazing
over a period of some months these
trainings that took place but the amount
of people who came out
i was surprised by the numbers because i
didn't know it would be that many people
but many people want to be part of this
part of these these kind of
healing efforts so i just had to note
that because it was really impressive
when we first started that without the
handkerchief
yeah that's great that was actually
going to be my next question because i
was curious just what the reception
had been like you know as we talked
about just people having that hesitancy
whether
people were open to that first aid
training mental health first day
training they feel like they needed it
but i mean just those numbers that you
mentioned
it seems like both the need and the
desire are really there which i think is
outstanding
dr king i'd be curious to hear your
thoughts on some of this as well you
know some of these topics that we're
talking about you know within the harlem
community what you've seen
you know in other parts of the country
or even nationally in terms of one
is there an openness to these
conversations or are people still
resistant
you know either in the faith community
or in the medical community
um to really have these integrated
conversations
yeah it's a great question i think the
hope center's such a great
model of success even though i know
there's ongoing challenges
around growth and sustainability uh
it might there are examples in other
parts of the country
uh of mental health centers and and
efforts that are
church-led uh in my experience they tend
to be successful
when three things are present one you
got to have a committed
church leadership that often leads from
a personal experiences
of church leaders and it shouldn't be
housed in just one
person like one pastor who's the
champion but it needs to be something
that
it's embraced by the community you got
to have
a specific leader of the initiative that
has the right kind of clinical wisdom
and training and skills and i think
both of those things are well
represented on our call today
professor mike and dr greene and you
also have to have a center that
understands its community and the needs
of its community
and is responding to specifically what's
present in the community and so these
efforts tend to look different in
different places in different cities
depending on what the needs are i with
respect to the broader questions i
i think you know around how
conversations about mental health are
happening in churches
and i have i'm interested in pastoring
dr green's perspective on this
um you know there's certainly a
stereotype out there that churches are
not safe spaces to talk about mental
health and mental illness and
that stereotype has grounding in reality
it's still often the case
that that's true i think over the last
10 or 15 years
actually i've noticed a lot more
willingness of people to talk
and engagement of churches and books
being written and things being
podcasts and things being published
where christians are talking about their
own experience of mental illness
where christians are calling the church
to be more active and engaged and so
that's all really good
and that's happened in a variety of
different church contexts it's happened
in a variety of different ways
including in black church settings so
monica coleman's book bipolar faith has
been something that
a lot of my students have found really
helpful in
destigmatizing mental illness in the
black community
uh and i think that all of that's really
important i think i think again
kind of going back to the pancreas work
i think one of the challenges is when
the church does begin to talk about
mental health
problems how not to make it just a
matter of individual people having
problems but how do we
how do we both recognize that mental
illness and mental health challenges are
deeply individual
and we can provide help to individuals
and to families and also to locate them
in a broader social cultural context
like what's happening in our
with our policies and with our programs
and with our where communities are
structured and things like housing
that might give rise to that and i think
that's where some of the conversations
around
church and mental health need to expand
some to
to have a kind of a broader social
perspective so it's not just a matter of
individual treatment seeking although
that's really important
yeah i think that's really well said and
it's helpful to hear some of those those
parallels and just to know what you're
equipping your students with as well and
i think you know all these pieces of
conversation are so
so powerful i'm curious you know for
those who are listening
from two sides who may be listening who
may be a member of a faith community a
member of a church
and are listening and saying that all
these things sound great and they sound
like they're great initiatives and it's
good to be able to have the vision and
to plug into resources
but those who feel isolated and don't
know where to start
so people who may have you know try to
approach questions of mental health
within the church and feel like they're
getting
pushed back and they don't know where to
go to do any of you have advice
for someone in that situation about how
to move forward
and then you know at the same time what
if that person is actually a leader so
someone who's in a leadership position
but feels like the leadership is not in
line with them
where do those individuals and how do
they how do they
really plug in to really get to a better
place
um i i i think you know
here's the reality there are a lot of
churches we've all agreed to this
earlier there are a lot of churches
um where we have
over spiritualized what we know to be
mental health
issues and because of that
and because many churches still operate
within certain theological traditions
in certain theological frameworks
that tragically don't make room for the
possibility
that there's something here at work
beyond the demonic
it is amazing how today in 2021
that with all the data with all the
research with all the work that is being
done around
mental health issues that there are
still people who approach this with a
primitive frame of mind
and and who do not acknowledge
that there are issues at stake
that are not that are beyond the the
narrative
of of demon possession or we need to
pray this away or we need to pray
fast and terry and all these things
so i think for people who in those kind
of spaces
one i don't think that they ought to
discount the reality that they live or
know because what happens is that when
you enter certain spaces that do not
acknowledge these realities
there is a sense of dismissiveness that
can be destructive
um and even disastrous for people not
just who want to talk about it or
acknowledge what people who are living
in these spaces
because what what churches have to also
acknowledge
is that we have participated in those
who have been silenced and remain silent
in their suffering because of sometimes
the lack of empathy and
even the punitive language that emerges
from some of our faith institutions so
what i would tell someone is do not let
the behavior of a particular institution
become definitive for the possibilities
of what can
happen and like it's the same thing
church you have to find a space and a
place
that values that that affirms this
that not only affirms the reality of of
mental health issues but also
is doing what dr green looked to earlier
you can pray
and get therapy you can be a deep
believer in god and seek treatment
um and i'm a witness to that and i also
think
that one of the other things that have
to happen is you know we've
i've gone i've gone i've been on panels
i've had
talks but i think there needs to be
gatherings as well and
and we're doing something like that dr
greenhill is doing something like this
in the fall
but gathering of clergy being able to
pull clergy together
um whether it is in
even in seminary you know and i don't
you know i'm a proud graduate of duke
divinity school but i don't know if
warren uh king honda came home was there
we had this conversation
you have many divinity schools that no
longer
make a requirement pastoral care and
counseling to graduate with a degree in
divinity
which is amazing because now
you have persons who are leading
institutions who may not have had even
a modicum of understanding of issues
around mental health and mental wellness
so i mean those are some ways but
getting clergy together
to begin to hear narratives because what
you will discover
clergy to suffer in silence because of
the expectation
um that people have of clergy to be the
problem solvers the healers
but as dr green alluded to there comes a
time when the healers need healing
to deal with their own psychic fractures
and i'll give it to you anecdotally
what really triggered me
in a major way to to really commit to
this initiative of the hope center was a
friend of mine a good friend of mine
that i went to college with
had another friend that i knew
marginally though but i knew of him
and uh on a sunday morning he had two
services at his church at eight
eight o'clock at an eleven o'clock
service and
um on this particular sunday his family
his wife and children two children were
at home getting ready they missed the
first service
and we're coming to the 11 o'clock
service so he goes to church
he preached the 8 o'clock sermon for the
service
he went home between services they
didn't live far from the church and his
wife and kids were getting ready we're
ready
he said you all go ahead i'll meet you
to church i have to do a couple of
things
and so the wife and the children left to
go to church
he's getting ready to preach the 11
o'clock servant and left the house
went in his car went in the driveway
took out a gun
and shot himself in the head so after
preaching the 8 o'clock
service he committed suicide right
and what was amazing is is that talking
to my friend
um that at the funeral no one mentioned
suicide
no one mentioned that there was some
kind of depression going because he had
been battling depression for some
time and hadn't really only shared it
with a few friends there was
as if he just died of natural causes
and no conversation during or no after
or before about what this man had been
suffering with
that is because the family was still
hasn't in fear i imagine of the stigma
connected
that a pastor because ideas if you trust
god
if you believe in god why and you know
you lean into god in prayer why would
you need to commit suicide and so
the people surrounding him still bought
into that narrative
and were almost ashamed to speak about
the fact that this pastor committed
suicide
there um if you look at some of the
numbers i know dr king i mean some years
ago i think
duke had done a study about the number
of clergy
who are actually committing suicide um
and the clergy
amount of clergy studies show about
suffering depression
and i mean it is amazing but again
if there's any group of people who are
suffering silence it is pastors
who have these great expectations heaped
upon them from congregations
that they're almost invincible and
nothing can penetrate
the strength that they have been endowed
with by god
and so they suffer in silence
yeah that's so important so important
and i appreciate you
you're bringing it out and just i mean
so so much that needs to be
is that something that you all have
tried to tackle head on
in the work in the hope center i mean
what would you what do you feel like is
different about what you're doing there
um i would say directly in terms of
clergy
no but i think what we've been doing
in the hope center uh i i like what with
dr green i wanted to
talk more about it but there's clinical
work but i think
where a lot of the attraction has taken
place with regard to changing the
narrative is a lot of the public facing
work she talked about
um i think that is to me
um there's no that's where a lot of the
weight
of the potential we have for impact um
really goes and i
would love to hear her to expound on
that more because of what that means
when we
we have these programs these wellness
check-ins and the like and i'd like to
talk more about that
i think it goes a long way in terms of
the public realizing that
this institution is is about more than
just saying hey
if you have something going on mentally
come over to us no it's about life
and wealth and wellness and well-being
yes all i know dr green how are people
responding to the public facing
component um our our response i think
has been
really great um i would say at the end
at the beginning of the pandemic
um the hope center engaged into um
virtual opportunities that both happen
on facebook so we started doing
mindfulness moments
so 30 30 minutes of mindfulness based
practices so anything from breath work
to yoga to meditation
um so that happens every tuesday and
then every thursday we have
our wellness check-ins again those are
virtually as well
and people are able to just pop on and
just sort of get a word an encouraging
word
um for 15 to 20 minutes from someone and
i have an array of people that
participate so they're either pastors
they might be a motivational speaker
they are our interns our clinical
interns here
um i've done a couple when i have to
um but we invite folks who have you know
just sort of like upbeat personalities
and then also clinicians to to join us
um to do those virtual moments twice a
week and those have been great
um we've also partnered with an
organization called mixed fitness
so they've been joining us because they
are um
a group of wellness and fitness
instructors
who come on once a month and participate
um
in our virtual mindfulness moments and
share something with us so whether it's
fitness whether it's stressing
whether it's um
[Music]
tapping meditation um for anxiety
um so it's been great we've gotten a lot
of positive feedback on that and also
too
those um those uh sessions live on
facebook and so
people can share them or they can watch
them as often as they'd like
um so those have been fantastic for us
and so we
um we're trying to think about you know
how do we continue to continue to offer
these things
as we move sort of out of the kingdom
and the world opens up a little bit more
yeah what does that look like now that
people have to go in
um the other things that we've been
doing that are public facing
are just um doing groups so we've had
some fantastic response to our group so
we did a group
for new and expected parents and an
eight-week group that sort of focused on
an
array of um different issues that are
important to
to moms um whether it's you know getting
ready for baby
postpartum depression um understanding
the the ways in which you can get care
including adding a doula which is
important because
um for particularly for women of color
black women
um there's a issue around maternal
mortality rates right and so we want to
figure out how to support them around
that and as well as
you know their maternal mental health um
we provided
a cdt based skills group as well that
actually has been our most popular group
to date
um and again all of our services are
free um for may we're going to be doing
wellness wednesdays
um so that's going to be a four week
series and then in june we have
something just for the guys
that's going to be focused on unmasking
masculinity and that's going to be led
by our male therapist here
um and we perhaps we get another puppet
so
um and then we just finished our hope
center weekend where uh pastor mike
and our um in-house male clinician were
able to focus
on um a men's talk so we're figuring out
ways in which we can you know again
bump up the public facing opportunities
um because we know that people may not
necessarily be ready to start individual
therapy
but in all of those opportunities we
certainly make the pitch for it
we provide resources so we have a a
number where folks can text
to get services we always provide our
national suicide hotline number
where folks can call and then you know
at any given point we provide resources
to all of the groups in the program
that we provide so we try to continue to
keep the conversation going
um and remind folks that you know
services are here free
here at the hope center and that they
can call
and or go online and sign up to to get
an appointment and it's free
and confidential and so that is i think
the
important messages that we try to try to
share consistently so that folks know
that there's a resource available yeah
and again that's so
across the board in terms of topics and
all those pieces i think that's that's
wonderful
how are people walking into that space i
mean is there are people walking in kind
of in a
you know are you creeping in don't want
to be seen are people open and
enthusiastic is a mixture of both
i mean you talked about that some of the
conversations that you have trying to
break that stigma there's so many rich
resources you're providing i'm just
curious how people are how they entering
in
in the first place yeah so everyone's
virtually entering in
our doors aren't open right now although
you know there there's a number of the
staff who were here um during the week
um so our interns our executive
assistant myself we're here
during the week um but all of our
services are virtual um and people can
actually call so they can call and get a
live person haven't have to
or they can go on and sign up
confidentially um
and then i go ahead and assign someone
um to
a therapist sign a potential innovator
to a therapist
and then they go ahead and get a phone
call and email so we do about three to
four outreach attempts
um in in an effort to get them engaged
into therapy
um and then if not they go back onto the
waiting list because we
continue to have a waiting list um and
even with
you know myself we also have a
psychologist we work with dr hankerson
who's a psychiatrist and then
you know we've had nine interns so even
with nine interns
um and the clinical staff who still had
a significant waiting list so
you know that's how we offer the groups
too right so people have an opportunity
well that's great in a lot of ways it
seems like i mean in some ways the
virtual piece may have helped to give
people that space
to not i mean not that the stigma
doesn't have to be dealt with at some
point but just to really
be able to enter in and i would imagine
that having the experience may even
also help as people are getting exposed
to all these resources may even help
break down that stigma and
make other opportunities uh going
forward so and
as you hint it i guess that will be a
challenge coming back
into the wall in a sense to see how that
dynamic will go forward
yeah um i i certainly think that virtual
programming is here to stay right um i
don't think that we'll ever go back to
you know non-virtual services whether
it's for medical appointments or for
mental health appointments
um i think we've all had some you know a
major learning curve during the pandemic
around you know how do we provide these
services good quality services in a
virtual space
um and so you know i would say prior to
the pandemic you know i was
probably a therapist that was on the
fence about you know
being in the room um with someone
because of all the things that you
receive from one another as you're
working towards your wellness journey
right
but certainly been able to do that in a
virtual space and i'm grateful for that
opportunity so we've all been we've all
been zooming
yeah yeah yeah that makes sense in a lot
of ways and you know even thinking back
to you know those individuals who may
feel like they don't have that support
in their own location i don't know if
you've seen that at all from
people from other faith communities you
know again getting back to what pastor
michael mentioned who feel like they can
step
into this and maybe a different faith
community that has moved the
conversation before and that has some of
those
pieces available so i think you know
those things are are options for people
as well that can also provide a lot of
opportunity that wasn't there in the
past in some ways yeah
absolutely and i've been able to do some
presentations
um with some communities of faith
um whether it's through the our the
mayor's office or
the um consortium through um one of the
hospitals
and so you know folks i think are a
little bit open to having me come and
present and talk about the hope center
and the services that we provide here
and while our you know um pastor mike
shared that
the hope center was originally created
to provide services to the congregation
um you know we don't turn anyone away so
we have people who
um are receiving services who are you
know members of our our
cvc community but they may be in paris
um
or germany or ireland and so you know
we're i'm excited that we're global and
that you know folks can
you know touch base and get and get
treatment no matter where they are no
yeah that's not so powerful an expansion
in some ways as well
so it was i mean there's still this is
such a rich conversation so many pieces
to to pull out and
again i'm just grateful for you know
some of the practical phones you talked
about as well because i think for
listeners a lot of those will go
a long way specifically for those who
feel isolated in their specific
situations
but as we continue to start to wrap up
uh dr kinghorn i was going to ask you
know
from your perspective as someone again
on both sides both the psychiatrists and
a theologian who's working in divinity
school
and as someone who's admired the work of
the hope center what
what do you use what is giving you hope
in the work that you're doing yourself
and in the work that you're seeing
pastor mike and dr green doing in terms
of how we're moving things forward
uh it's a it's a great question i think
i i
am feeling i think it's important to
hold hope
and challenge together that you can only
really understand what hope is when you
are willing to see the enormity of
challenge uh
and and i think that both uh in terms of
what we've been describing today and in
terms of christian faith i think that
there is
we have a lot of resources uh so on one
hand i think that the challenges are
immense and especially the challenges
and the pandemic are immense
everything that's happening in the world
all around us
i also think that uh that it's tempting
in the midst of big challenges
to hit despair to think like this is
just the way it's going to be
we just have to hunker down we just have
to push through and i think our our
christian faith uh teaches us that
we are loved by god before all else
and that humans are created with dignity
and an image of god and that
uh and and and also that god is already
doing the work of healing
before us and around us and that we
don't generate this ourselves through
our own
like energy and time and you know as if
we're decreeing
but we're participating in god's
ongoing healing work in the world and so
as a
as a psychiatrist who's also a christian
i want to say how do i just
kind of join in that lane to like join
in the work that the holy spirit is
already doing
in the world and that god takes maybe
some of the
felt pressure off of me but it also puts
pressure on me to like continue to
seek out that space in that area um and
so i think
and i also think that that i as a
psychiatrist i can often get in the mode
of fixing like
patients presenting me with a problem i
got to fix them and i think as
the our faith gives us a different kind
of frame that we
are not machines that need to be fixed
but we are those who are on a journey
i from god to god and this this
life is a kind of journey uh through
life to god and we walk
we ourselves are on a journey and anyone
whom we
try to help or to minister to or with is
also on a journey so
we walk as wayfarers alongside others on
a journey and so we can ask ourselves
like what's needed right now
for the journey and that makes it very
practical because what's needed
might be a medication what's needed
might be a course of ect
or tms or what's needed might be a 12
session course of psychotherapy or
what's needed might be
a men's group or what's needed might be
a meal or to get out of an abusive
relationship
and so i think i think that that being a
christian gives me permission to think
broadly about those kinds of things and
to and and hope that uh
that this work didn't start with me or
us or any of us
on this uh episode it doesn't end with
us but it's going on and we get a chance
to participate in that
and that gives me hope and then just to
see witnesses like pastor mike and dr
greene
and others in other places doing really
creative work i look at that and i think
man this is so deeply needed and uh to
be able just to see that unfold and to
celebrate it is something that i think
is just really profoundly encouraging
wow that's so well said and i just love
that approach too and the framework
of really just looking at things
holistically and bringing
all aspects and all tools to the table
so definitely appreciate you
sharing that and i know you're being
humble but i know you're deeply involved
in that work in so many ways as well
so deeply appreciate for the way that
you're doing that and the way that
you're impacting
the next generation of folks who will be
doing this both
as clinicians as psychiatrists as
pastors and teachers so i also just
wanted to acknowledge that and
make sure that yeah that's acknowledged
and known to our audience as well
thank you duterte and all of us i think
are in that role in
on this on this call so thank you
dr green what about you you know even
that you know that juxtaposition goes
back to what you mentioned at the
beginning about
even your own personal challenges in the
midst of the hope
that you have as a christian and the
hope that you're providing in your work
how do you
continue to think about that going
forward so
um you know dr kinghorn said it so
so perfectly too um i think about how do
we do this
um work and how we call to do this work
and we're always called to do it in
relationship
right and so that's what really is at
the heart of what we're trying to do and
therapy
and groups on this healing journey is
that i'm walking alongside you in this
relationship on this healing journey
and you know how can i support you um on
this and how do i learn right because
you know i tell folks all the time when
they come here and they you know dr
kinghorn mentioned
you know we want to fix but also our
clients or our innovators expect
expect us to fix it right um and so i
also say to people you're the expert
on your own life right i'm here to
listen
i'm here to maybe pick out some things
that maybe you didn't you weren't aware
of
or um to challenge you in new and
different ways or expand your thinking
but you're the expert on that and and
we're both learning in this space
together
um and so i think that's an important um
lens to have and working with with
people who are on this journey to
healing
um and then also just continually
thinking about you know how do i
personally
intentionally cultivate spaces of joy
what does that look like for me on a
daily and consistent basis
right and i don't sometimes i don't do
it every single day um
right but reminding myself to be
intentional about it uh reminding the
people around me to be intentional about
it
um and holding myself accountable right
yeah that's so well said i love that
that relational piece and
holding ourselves accountable to joy i
mean i think that goes that goes such a
long way
pastor mike to wrap up there's so much
that's been said here
um i guess not even just hope for
yourself but you know if you'd be able
to encourage our listeners too in ways
to continue to find hope because i'm
sure there are those who are listening
who are struggling and who are trying to
find a way out any any uh
where did you want to speak to them
directly yeah there's a
a many years ago a line i heard i
read by late um howard thurman who has
served as one of my own spiritual and
theological mentors along my journey as
a believer and
as a pastor and he was frequent to say
that the contradictions of life are not
final
and i think in these past 18 months
we've seen
many harsh realities that have sought
to um in some places assault life
undermine life
and have given birth birth to many um
many realities that many of us did not
know were even possibilities for us
meaning depressive moments
moments filled with anxiety that this
pandemic brought to the forefront
but i think it's always a good reminder
to tell people
for me personally that those
contradictions are not final they do not
hold the final word they are not
definitive on our lives
that we have not only power through god
but transcendent power to overcome
and see our way through these kinds of
seasons
one of our pastors sermon last sunday
and she focused
on psalm 23 and the particular verse
when
the psalmist says david in particular
you know yea though i walk through the
valley of the shadow of
death i will fear no evil but thou art
with me
that that confidence that the writer
exhibits that
that um audacity
is shaped by an experience with god for
thou
art with me and i think at the end of
the day for believers
who are finding themselves dealing with
mental health challenges we cannot
forget
the presence of god because it is
through god i think that resources
emerges through god that opportunities
come to the forefront and it is also
through god
that new and innovative pathways towards
healing and
wholeness become visible so those
contradictions are not
final the best is all is yet to come
and it does not appear what we shall be
when we trust that we're being led
and guided and directed by a god who at
the end of the day
wants to see us to be the best versions
of ourselves
wow so powerful so well said
amen well
i'm just in awe of just you know
everything that's that we've gone
through and even
what's happened this last hour during
our conversation and you know what's
been happening over the years
at the hope center and grateful grateful
for uh
the trust that you all have put in god
and one another to be able to
walk in relationship like dr green said
in a lot of ways and walking
relationship with those in your
community i think that's
it goes a long way and i'm sure that
it's uh it's important
to the community and acknowledged even
in times when it's challenging so
that yeah that gives me hope just even
hearing hearing this story
today and these stories that you all
shared so thank you so much pastor mike
dr green dr king horn for jumping on the
adi hour podcast i know this is going to
be one of those that people are going to
be able to go back and listen to and
i appreciate the way you spoken so
poignantly to our listeners
as well and been so real and honest at
the same time
well thank you for having me and thanks
for having us this has been great and
i'm
i'm grateful the opportunity just to
share and be part of this conversation
thank you so much
well great being with all of you and for
all of our listeners stay tuned for some
upcoming episodes of the addy hour
continue just like we did today to
really dig deep into some of these
topics and
really have real and honest
conversations i think can empower us and
encourage us all
so until next time
you